this is this is what i do
i make a dumb case for things and then
you shut me down
and then the internet says how dumb lex
is this is good this is how
it works good it's shutting down and and
they're foolish in uh blaming you for
the question because
well you're here to ask me questions
let's let's make the
let me make a case for socialism
so it's gonna be bad yes
there is for social media right that's
reality so
and then perhaps it's not a case for
socialism but just
a certain notion that inequality
the wealth and equality that the bigger
the gap between the poorest or the
average
and the richest the the more painful it
is to be
average psychologically speaking
if you know that there is the ceos
of companies make 300 a thousand
one million times more than you do that
makes
life for a large part of the population
less fulfilling that there's a relative
notion to the experience of our life
that even though everybody's life has
gotten better over the past
decades and centuries it may feel
actually worse because
you know that life could be so so much
better
than in life of these ceos that uh
yeah that gap is fundamentally uh a
thing that
is undesirable in a society
everything about that is wrong
[Music]
okay i like to start off like that yeah
which
so yeah i mean so my wife likes to
remind me
that as well as we've done in life we
are actually from a wealth perspective
closer to a homeless person than we are
to bill gates just the math right just
the math right
it's a good go check when i look at bill
gates
i get a smile on my face i love bill
gate i've never met broke it yeah
i love bill gates yeah i love what he
stands for
i love that he has a hundred billion
dollars i
love that he has built a trampoline room
in his house where his kids can jump up
and down in a trampoline
in a safe environment can we take
another billionaire
because i'm not if you're sure if you're
paying attention but
there's all kinds of conspiracy theories
about bill gates so
well but that's part of the story right
they have to pull him down because
people resent him
but yes we can take jeff bezos yeah we
can say uh you know my favorite
stock leads because i i like i like a
lot about him was with steve jobs
um i mean i love these people
and i can't they're very few
billionaires i don't love
in a sense that i appreciate everything
they've done for me
for people i cherish and love
they've made the world a better place
why
would it ever cross my mind
that they make me look bad because
they're richer than me or that i don't
have what they have
they've made me so
much richer that they've made
inventions that used to cost millions
and millions and millions of dollars
accessible to me i mean this is a super
computer
in my pocket now but think about it
right
what is the difference between and i'll
get to the essence of your point in a
minute
but think about what the difference is
between me and bill gates
in terms of because it's true that in
terms of wealth i'm closer to the
homeless person
but in two in terms of my day-to-day
life i'm closer to bill gates
you know we both live in a nice house
his is nicer
but we live in a nice house his is
bigger but mine is plenty big
we both drive cars his is nicer but we
both drive cars cars
100 years ago what cause we
both flock can fly get on a plane in los
angeles and flight in new york and get
that about the same time
we're both flying private the only
difference is
my private plane i share with 300 other
people and his
but it's accessible it's relatively
comfortable again in the perspective of
50 years ago 100 years ago
it's unimaginable that i could fly like
that for for such a low fee
we live very similar lives in that sense
um
so i don't resent him so first of all
i'm an exception to the supposed rule
that people visit i don't think anybody
i don't think people do resent unless
they're taught to present
and this is the key people are taught
and i've seen this in america and this
is to me
the most horrible shocking thing that
has happened in america over the last
40 years i came to america so i'm an
immigrant i came to america from israel
in 1987. and i came here because
i thought this was the place where i
could where it had the most
opportunities and it is
most opportunities and i came here
because i believed there was some
a certain american spirit of
individualism
and exactly the opposite of what you
just described a a
sense of i live my life it's
my happiness i'm not looking at my
neighbor i'm not competing with the
jones just the american dream is my
dream
my two kids my dog my station wagon not
because other people have it it's
because i want it in that sense
and when i came here in the 80s
you had that you had you still had it it
it was less than i think it had been in
the past but you had that spirit
there was no envy there was no
resentment there were rich people
and and they were celebrated there was
still this
admiration for entrepreneurs and
admiration for success
not by everybody certainly not by the
intellectuals but by the average
person i have witnessed particularly
over the last
10 years a complete transformation and
america's become like europe
i know are you russian yeah yeah it's
become
russian in a sense where
you know they've always done these
studies um you know i'll give you
a hundred dollars and your neighbor a
hundred dollars or give you
uh was it yeah or give you uh
a thousand dollars but your neighbor
gets ten thousand dollars
and a russian will always choose the
hundred dollars right he he wants
equality
above being better himself yeah
americans would always choose
that gap and that's like chance is not
anymore
and it's changing because
we've been told it should change and
morally you're saying that
doesn't make any sense so there's no
sense in which
let me put another spin i forget the
book but
the sense of if you're working for steve
jobs and you
your hands you're the engineer behind
the iphone
and there's a sense in which his salary
is stealing from your efforts
because i forget the book right that's
literally the terminology is used this
is straight out of
uh called sure yeah it's it's also
straight but
out of karl marx but like there's no
sense morally speaking
that you see that as the other way
around that engineer's stealing off of
and it's not stealing right it's not but
the engineers getting more from
from steve jobs by a lot not by a little
bit than steve jobs
is getting from the engineer the
engineer even if they're a great
engineer
they're probably other great engineers
that could replace him
would he even have a job without steve
jobs would the industry exist without
steve jobs
without the giants that carry these
things forward
and let me ask you this i mean you're a
scientist yes do you resent einstein for
being smarter than you
i mean you envy him do you are you angry
with him would you
would you would you feel negative
towards him if he was in the room right
now or would you if he came into the
room you'd say
oh my god i mean you interview people
who i think some of them
are probably smarter than you and me
yeah for sure and your attitude towards
them is one of reverence
you